ce que vous voyez sur les routes
oui bonjour ni nabli bien tout ce que
nous voyons depuis deux semaines c'est
toujours la même scène avec ses
centaines ces milliers de voitures qui
viennent de l'est et qui parcourt l'est
l'ukraine d'est en ouest en direction
peut-être de l'union européenne
certaines familles cherchent qu'à se
réfugie encore dans le pays en espérant
que le vivent par exemple qui est l'une
des cibles de ces familles ne soient pas
visés par le russe ou alors d'autres
familles nous en raconter tout
simplement qu'elle cherchait à quitter
le pays par tous les moyens que ce soit
par la pologne la slovaquie lambris voir
encore la roumanie mais encore une fois
ce qu'ils peuvent attendre ces familles
une fois la frontière passée et bien
c'est un déchirement site une séparation
puisque les hommes entre 18 et 55 ans
ont l'obligation de rester dans le pays
suite à la mobilisation générale
décrétée par le président hans qui est
donc une fois que ces familles sont
arrivées à la frontière une seconde
épreuve les attend après des jours et
des jours de traversée c'est la
séparation et on a déjà vu on a déjà pu
le constater
excusez moi on a déjà pu le constater à
travers différents reportages la douleur
que ces familles là deux secondes
douleur que ces familles peuvent endurer
des familles qui ont tout quitté
précipitamment à suite au bombardement
de leur ville ou de leur région et qui
ne savent pas si un jour alpes ou
retrouver un jour leur maison il ya
aussi cette peur dont je j'ai déjà parlé
à plusieurs reprises cette peur qui est
latente qui est présente partout même si
on est encore loin d'une zone de guerre
comme kiev ou comme kharkiv est bien
cette peur elle est présente pourquoi
parce que il y a sur la route des
stations essence qui ont été bombardés
ces derniers jours et ce sont des cibles
évidemment stratégique de la part de
l'armée russe pour empêcher les gens de
pouvoir faire leur plein d'essence plein
d'essence qui pour l'instant est encore
assez relativement aisé à faire mais les
gens redoutent que dans les prochains
jours cela soit ça soit beaucoup plus
compliqué on a vu beaucoup de personnes
notamment équipé de jerricanes remplir
remplir leurs jerrycans d'essence pour
tout simplement essayer de prévenir une
éventuelle pénurie qui n'est pas encore
là dans la région il y à cette peur il
ya aussi les sirènes qui retentissent à
chaque étape que nous faisons des
sirènes qui retentissent le jour le midi
le soir hier encore il était environ 22
heures lorsque la sirène de vinnitsa les
sirènes ont retenti les gens il n'y a
pas eu de panique cette fois ci puisque
les gens ont l'air en fait d'avoir pris
entre guillemets l'habitude de ces
alertes ils se sont réfugiés très
tranquillement dans le bunker de l'hôtel
il ya comme une forme de résilience de
la part de de cette population mais
aussi beaucoup de fatigue psychologique
à chaque étape que nous voyons donc
c'est la même scène et je voulais aussi
faire un petit point sur la la
solidarité nationale ukrainienne puisque
dans tous les hôtels où nous demeurons
et bien à chaque fois les hôtels met à
disposition des familles de réfugiés d
des chambres qui puisque les hôtels
savent que ces familles ont besoin d'un
logis au moins pour une soirée pouvoir
ensuite continué leur route vers vers
l'ouest à l'heure actuelle on parle de
plus d'un million et demi de déplacés
dans tout le pays est déjà plus de
650000 ou quitter l'ukraine merci
beaucoup l'une est un pur